maybe for the viewer that hasn't had the
ability to talk to somebody to know what
kind of
money lobbyists make what is the
business model for the lobbyists not
not the you know politician but the
actual lobbyists representing the
company what is their business
model uh well their business model is to
take their position and their position
may have been as a congressional staffer
it may have been for a member of
congress
and then when they leave office whether
they retire from congress or they
leave as a congressional staff or
they're voted out of office as a member
of congress
is to become a lobbyist and to go to the
very people
uh that you perform services for while
you were in office
and to now get paid um so you know
think about it that think about it this
way sometimes there are transactions
where if i'm purchasing something from
you
you give me a good and i pay you back
directly
sometimes if we're exchanging a service
you perform a service
and we sign a retainer agreement i don't
pay you the full amount but i pay you a
certain amount every month
just to make sure that we have that
retainer agreement lobbying is very
similar
oftentimes they use the retainer model
so if i'm the powerful men
you know powerful chairman of a
congressional committee i decide to
retire me i become a lobbyist let's say
i was chairman of the house
budget committee enormous power
influence on federal government spending
i'm going to set up a lobbyist shop
and what's going to happen is all the
government contractors
all the individuals who are getting
government money are now going to hire
me
as a lobbyist and i can make 50 000
a month just from one client and i might
have 15 or 20 clients at the same time
basically what i'm going to use is my
position as the former chairman of the
committee
to do what i'm going to go to the
current occupant
and i'm going to say look i need you to
do me a favor i have this client that
needs this written
into legislation or they need this this
favor done
and the print occupants based on the way
it works in washington dc
is going to play ball why are they going
to play ball
because when they leave as chairman of
the house budget committee
they're probably going to do the same
thing so it's a business model
in a system that is on rotation
um and it's very you know infrequently
talked about
uh it's very infrequently discussed why
because both
sides do it um it's it's one of the few
things in washington that's still
bipartisan
but this ability to make money as a
member of congress
when you really don't necessarily even
have any other skill set
other than the fact that you know other
people in positions of power
is an enormously alluring way to make
money
and nobody wants to disrupt that so it's
not uncommon to make five to ten million
a year as a lobbyist if you're a good
lobby oh yeah that's absolutely right
um and also you know to be clear there's
a lot that you can do
in the area of let's say government
relations
um that's not technically lobbying but
but it's essentially the same thing with
a few slight modifications so
you take a guy uh like senator tom
daschle
uh former uh a leader for democrats in
the u.s senate he's been out
for uh uh for a while uh but tom
daschler will say i'm not a lobbyist i'm
in government relations
but what does he do he represents
pharmaceutical companies and others
that have it beef or that have a problem
or want a favor
from the federal government and as long
as he doesn't cross that threshold
into being a lobbyist whereby he diverts
a certain amount of his time
to asking for specific legislation to
pass
he can avoid being labeled the lobbies
but he's still pulling in 50
000 a month from a client doing favors
and getting benefits from washington dc
i mean that's real money making five to
ten million a year you got you got
pretty good
lifestyle now why do some of these guys
like if nancy wanted to leave and
say i don't want to do what i'm doing
anymore i'm going to go out there and be
a lobbyist and open up my own place and
make a bunch of money why why is she
staying in why
is schumer staying in because the money
isn't that good i mean i saw her network
the other day 140 million dollars i
don't know how she's 140 million dollars
and i saw that 60 minute by the way but
why aren't some of them
leave in to make more money as a
lobbyist
that's a good question i mean some
people i guess have you know different
different motivations but i think to be
more to the point
there are people in washington dc that
are in elective office
and have been there for decades who have
mastered the art
of enriching themselves what i would
call again legal graft
but they use their position as a member
of congress to self-enrich themselves
and let me just give you a couple of
examples one would be uh issues relating
to
stock market manipulation and favor and
this would be an example with nancy
pelosi
so let's say you are a senator from the
great state of texas
and i want a favor if i walk in and i
give you a shoe box
with a hundred thousand dollars in cash
um
we're going to be in trouble because
that's illegal i can't pay you a bribe
you can't accept a bribe and insurance
in exchange for a favor
but consider this and this is something
naturally pelosi has done for decades
but consider this
i need a favor from you senator um and
oh by the way i'm connected with this
company
that's going to be going public um and
and
i can get you access to the friends and
family
round of ipo stock whereby you can buy
stock for pennies on the dollar
and when this stock goes public you're
gonna make a hundred thousand dollars in
a single day
now if that's our conversation
that's actually not illegal uh and nancy
pelosi has done
this i mean we found uh in our
investigation with 60 minutes
uh at at least uh eight instances where
she and her husband
got access to ipo shares of stock before
companies went public
and these were companies that had
legislation
sitting before her in congress the most
extreme example was
visa the credit card company that went
public in 2008
um she and her husband got five thousand
uh uh pre-ipo shares of stock in that
company
visa had legislation they wanted killed
she killed that legislation
when visa went public pelosi and her
husband made a hundred thousand dollars
in a single day
um so that's one example of how this
works so
you don't have to leave office
necessarily to cash in
if you're smart and clever and willing
to frankly be corrupt
there are things that you can do in
office let me give you another example
of how it works
and that would be what i would call the
land deal uh and here
i can cite examples of harry reid the
former senator from nevada
i can also talk about dennis hastert the
former republican speaker of the house
in general dennis hastert's case um
his net worth when he became speaker of
the house
was minimal it was a couple hundred
thousand dollars by the time he left
only eight years later he was worth
millions of dollars
now how does that happen he's a former
wrestling coach
went into congress how did that happen
well he used what i call the land deal
so he's the speaker of the house he buys
himself individually as a private
citizen as he can
a a parcel of land in the middle of
nowhere in illinois where he's from
i mean this is rural illinois in the
middle of nowhere gets the land very
cheap
within 18 months he is the speaker of
the house
uh introduces the highway transportation
bill
for federal subsidies to transportation
in that bill
includes legislation for something
called the prairie parkway
which is going to run where through
illinois which is going to run where
right by the property that he had
purchased a year and a half
earlier the valuation of that land went
up
dramatically he made literally half a
million dollars just
in that one deal and here's the scary
part what he did
was exposed it's not illegal
it's not illegal to do what he did so
there are many things
that elected officials in office can do
right now
to self-enrich themselves that's why
nancy pelosi is now worth more than a
hundred million dollars
uh having been in congress for the last
30 years her husband's a businessman
a lot of his business deals dovetailed
very nicely
with the legislation that she's working
on in washington